[Musica]
cosa stiamo restituendo al mondo non
come collettività ma ognuno di noi
cosa sta restituendo dico questo perché
per me non è scontato stare al mondo in
un modo o nell'altro
alla fine di questa bellissima
esperienza chiamata vita ognuno di noi
avrà restituito qualcosa
sapete qual è il mio modo di restituire
l'arte l'arte è per me chiaramente forse
il più grande gesto di restituzione come
mettere al mondo un figlio perché è così
che funziona l'arte alla capacità unica
incredibile di farmi sentire parte di
tutte le cose oltre il senso di
separazione io diverso da te quella cosa
incredibile che mi fa sentire unico
unico unico al mondo perché io voglio
guardare un panorama e sentirmi parte di
esso io voglio essere quel panorama
perché quel panorama dice tutto e invece
per capirlo devo descriverlo raccontarlo
e spiegarlo fotografarlo eccetera
eccetera
certo tutto bello e necessario ai fini
della comunicazione ma quando mi sono
innamorato per la prima volta non ci ho
pensato più di tanto mi sono innamorato
e basta michelangelo come il bernini
come leonardo come tanti altri grandi
maestri della tradizione è stato un
assoluto punto di riferimento per me da
piccolo guardavo con gli occhi di chi
avrebbe voluto essere esattamente come
lui o anche più grande ecco non mi
vergogno di dirlo parlo di quella
desiderio fondamentale che ogni bambino
dovrebbe avere no di come dire ambire
alla grandezza
certo è chiaro che è un paragone
esagerato
quanti di voi ma facciamo un po di
coraggio hanno avuto un punto di
riferimento da piccoli che hanno sognato
di essere grande come britney spears per
esempio ma sicuramente quanti dai
proviamo quanti quanti se ne hanno avuto
amore mio del non sogna valigia perfetta
regia perfetta incredibile che cosa
volevi essere da grande
quello che se adesso bene ecco forse
quella la cosa più importante quella la
cosa più importante che abbiamo a
disposizione
comunque vi siete mai chiesti perché
l'arte importante importante per ognuno
di noi fondamentale
magari no non è necessario ecco proviamo
per un attimo ad immaginare che ci
vengono portati via tutti quei
capolavori di cui di solito ci vantiamo
perché noi siamo molto bravi in italia
neo ci vantiamo noi italiani quando
andiamo all'estero non quei capolavori
assoluti
ognuno ha il suo capolavoro ok parlo di
quelle cose che ci riguardano
profondamente se vi dico immagina il
bello delle immagini quell'opera d'arte
per esempio come vi sentite se
all'improvviso che venissero portate via
vuoti derubati sì o no discreto c'è
stato perché forse perché quelle cose
siamo noi perché noi siamo quelle opere
quelle opere d'arte sono la nostra
identità il nostro biglietto da visita
ecco l'italia è un'opera d'arte
un'opera d'arte veramente un'opera
d'arte
vogliamo negarlo la signora un po la
testa così per basta farci un giro qua
intorno
ok ecco l'italia e arte e che cos'è
l'arte l'arte è una bellissima cornice
utile necessaria la cornice è utile
necessaria ecco mi spiego meglio la
nostra italia è la nostra preziosa
cornice ma una cornice senza quadro non
serve a nulla
e qual è il quadro della nostra italia
siamo noi noi con le nostre scelte noi
con i nostri desideri
noi con le nostre gioie e i nostri
dolori noi con le nostre passioni noi in
questo momento
ecco noi possiamo essere il quadro più
bello o il più
brutto amandola onorandola rispettandola
nei suoi capolavori che sono immagine
specchio di ciò che noi stessi siamo
magari producendone di nuovi perché no
mica dobbiamo vivere per forza di
conservazione possiamo produrre delle
cose cioè ce l'abbiamo due mani possiamo
essere in grado di eccellere come voleva
e celere il bambino ok possiamo farla
questa cosa ma non è necessario diciamo
così essere dei grandi artisti
riconosciuti avere milioni di forum come
va di moda adesso no
per restituire qualcosa per dare
qualcosa non c'è bisogno di fare tanto
bastano piccoli gesti
basta buttare una cicca di sigaretta
nella pattumiera
certo possiamo non farlo ma dobbiamo
sapere capire che quella sarà la
pennellata che daremo su questa tela
condivisa ok il valore più grande
dell'arte che si tratta di un linguaggio
trasversale un collante universale
ecco lo so è difficile pensare che possa
esistere qualcosa in grado di unirci a
tal punto ora facciamo non posso uscire
da questo perimetro mi metto in
quest'altro che ancora proprio ecco
immaginiamo per un attimo così un gioco
da così non ci rilassiamo un attimo
perché se io vi divide in due gruppi un
gruppo alla mia destra gruppo alla mia
sinistra è un gioco e rilassiamoci un
attimo voi gruppo alla mia sinistra
veramente ditemi la verità ma che pensa
del gruppo di destra che pensa di
allora per bisogna metteremo in chiaro
le cose voi se ci avete un po d'orgoglio
che pensate del gruppo alla mia sinistra
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ai ragazzi non valete niente
potete fare molto meglio dai fan smart
forza che pensate del gruppo alla vostra
destra ci riproviamo
mi sa che che penso ecco vedete vanno
dopo una lezione comunque ok
ecco questo questo è il fatto il fatto
poi state già un passo in avanti perché
questo succede ogni giorno nelle nostre
vite ogni giorno accendiamo la
televisione e basta disegnare una linea
immaginaria fra due gruppi di persone
perché ci si faccia la guerra
questo è non ce ne rendiamo conto magari
facciamo un giro in aereo non sappiamo
dove stiamo bene saremo ancora qui noi
ne siamo dall'altra parte del mondo
perché sono è la nella nostra
immaginazione la differenza la
diversificazione siamo tutti uguali
invece l'arte l'arte alla capacità di
cancellare queste linee evidenziando
invece la nostra radice comune come
riproviamo we just avati su quella
lunghezza d'onda
ora voi che avete preso la lezione che
pensate il gruppo fa questo capolavoro
che pensate
e voi che pensate
ecco io credo che abbiamo fatto appena
un'opera d'arte opera d'arte
ecco se riusciamo a fare tesoro di
questo sentimento e ce lo portiamo
dietro nella nostra quotidianità
noi avremmo realizzato il capolavoro
della nostra esistenza
immaginate se ogni giorno potessimo fare
una cosa del genere che capolavoro è un
capolavoro madonna che capolavoro che
siete belli belli
bevete fuoco ma sia di sicuramente bene
comunque comunque quello che dove c'è
stato
diciamo un equivoco diciamo così che
molte volte mi chiedono che lavoro
faccio io sono un artista scultore e
loro ti dicono non fantastico
eccezionale incredibile cioè 30 anni
l'arte una cosa bellissima ma cavolo fai
questo succede questo è un dramma però
avendo una volta in discoteca mi dissero
lavoro lo scultore viene committee porto
nel privè così lui e costruttore di
tecnologia e infatti mano mandato fuori
si è così perché funziona in un certo
modo ma comunque c'è stato un rientro
nel cerchio quello dell'illuminazione
spostate adesso rimane la e c'è stato un
momento della mia vita in cui mi sono
reso conto che realtà non avevo limiti
perché l'unico il vero limite era qui
nella mia testa
questo è il fatto e in quel momento ho
compreso realizzato che avrebbe dovuto
fare qualsiasi cosa della mia esistenza
della mia vita non fare nulla oppure
essere qui in questo momento guardarvi
negli occhi e presentarmi il mio nome
iago e questo è quello che faccio
[Applauso]
si no
si chiama
[Musica]
[Applauso]
forse
[Musica]
no
ora
[Musica]
scusate
si no
[Musica]
se avete altri quattro minuti se volete
potete anche un secondo
secondo me lo fa una cosa i ragazzi
purtroppo non c'era nessuno stasera un
disastro assoluto io penso che me ne
vada adesso è una cosa vergognosa per un
grazie grazie al peggio